Robert Muller testifies on the hill the
media defend o Hanauma and the Justice
Department targets big tech I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show oh
[Music]
man it was the biggest news of the day
of the year of the century Robert Muller
was going to appear before the House
Judiciary and oversight committees and
my goodness
we were going to find out how long the
last what President Trump had done I
mean sure there was already a 448 page
report about it sure I remember yeah I
seem to remember reading the whole thing
because it was super boring and had some
spicy moments male in a great book or
anything and then I remember coming on
this show and summarizing it in detail
for like three straight days but that
wasn't enough the Democrats had to bring
Robert Muller in because they wanted to
grill him and they wanted to demonstrate
that in reality despite the fact that
Robert Muller had said he was not
hindered in his investigation despite
the fact that the investigation in fact
found no collusion with the Russians
despite the fact that the obstruction
charges were not sufficient to bring a
prosecution and that Robert Muller had
begged off the Democrats were under the
weird assumption that Robert Muller was
going to show up and he was gonna say
guys time for me to drop the pretense
and drop the pretense right now Trump is
guilty and you only you can impeach him
that was what the Democrats were hoping
for from this and so the build-up to
this event was magnificent folks in the
media were really really excited about
all of this folks in the media thought
well this will be the moment this will
be the moment when finally Trump is
brought to heel and so are Democrats
Democrats were very excited about this
he had representative ted Lieu from the
state of california saying mines are
gonna be blown it's gonna be incredible
basically this was like the build-up to
Ishtar we're gonna spend an awful lot of
money and there's gonna a lot of press
and then the movie was gonna be not very
good well that's how it kind of ended up
here's ted Lieu though really really
pumping up this thing as though it was a
lead a battle angel he's it like we're
just gonna pump this thing up here he is
explaining it's gonna blow your mind
it's like a James Cameron movie except
boring and with an old guy four people
we're read the malla reporter follow the
issues this will not be surprising
tomorrow but for people who have
not read the report or have only
listened to bill bar or Donald Trump
their minds may be blown because they're
gonna see facts that they never saw
they're gonna be seeing that the
president directed his White House
Council to fire the Special Counsel
that's a crime lunacy that the president
directed his White House Council to then
cover that up and create a fake document
that's a second crime and they're gonna
see that he directed Corey Lewandowski
to ask Jeff Sessions to limit their
investigation into Donald Trump that's a
third crime okay none of those are
current and none of those are crimes the
FIR the first in the third particularly
are not crimes he could have fired the
Special Counsel at any time it would
have been impeached but it would not
have been a crime he could have had Jeff
Sessions limit the scope mother's
investigation that wouldn't have been
impeachable it would not have been a
crime as far as instructing time again
to create a document for the press that
was not a crime right I mean that that
probably was not a crime at least not
sufficient to charge according to none
other than Robert Millar in any case the
media had really built this thing up
there's a piece by Bloomberg talking
about in high stakes Muller hearing
there are big risks for everyone
he said Robert Muller has vowed he won't
go beyond what he's already written
about Russia Donald Trump and
obstruction of justice when he testifies
on Wednesday but there's a lot at stake
in how much or how little he brings to
life the dry specifics of his 448 page
report wow it was going to be supremely
exciting and Democrats were hoping that
Americans would tune in well if they did
they were asleep by the end of the first
inning
this is a baseball game they were out by
the end of the first inning
representative David Cicilline he says
this is Congress saying no one is above
the law here's Chris Cuomo getting super
excited with David Cicilline well you're
not gonna learn anything tomorrow that
you don't know already the Democrats
aren't going to like this also to be
sure that the American people understand
understand their democracy that was
attacked they have a right to know this
this investigation was conducted on
their behalf it's important that the
person who led the investigation report
to the American people about his
findings about the evidence that he
uncovered and then it will be incumbent
on Congress to hold him accountable in
fact mr. Muller and the very final
paragraphs of the report says this is
Congress's responsibility to demonstrate
that no one is above the law
so Muller's performance was going to be
the big thing now it's worthwhile
reviewing what the Muller report
actually found there were several key
claim
in the Mullah report the first is that
the Trump Russia collusion claims were
farcical II overblown like really really
overblown
there are certainly members of the Trump
team who acted suspiciously including
President Trump who continued to tell
the American public no work was
occurring on the Trump Tower Moscow deal
during the 2016 campaign which of course
was not true but the Mullah report makes
it clear that all of this was really
really exaggerated is a quote from the
model report although the investigation
established that the Russian government
perceived it would benefit from a trump
presidency and worked to secure that
outcome and that the campaign expected
it would benefit electoral e for
information stolen and released through
russian efforts the investigation did
not establish that members of the Trump
campaign conspired or coordinated with
the Russian government in its election
interference activities the the melo
report also never really referred to the
steel dossier which apparently was the
basis of a lot of the investigation in
the first place
the mollow report revealed that when it
came to obstruction of justice that they
had no real clear definition sufficient
to prosecute the president or recommend
prosecution it found that Trump acted
perversely in a lot of ways this report
it found that he was threatening to fire
people he was trying to push his White
House Counsel Don McGann's who lied to
the press regarding from desire to fired
James Comey there's a lot of ugly stuff
in the report but there is nothing that
rises to the level of criminally
prosecuted behavior Trump's team
basically stopped him from violating the
law time and time again what the report
mostly reveals when it comes to
obstruction is that Trump was just
ticked off at his own goj and at his own
FBI because he felt he was being
unjustly persecuted by them the real
takeaway from the Muller report was here
is a bunch of information if Congress
wants to go forward with it if Congress
wants to impeach then that is a congress
problem Congress tried to throw this
back in Miller's lap today they tried to
basically get Muller to testify that
Trump should be impeached and Muller
that's not how it went now Republicans
basically expected this was going to
happen so Mitch McConnell the Senate
Majority Leader he said we're not gonna
find anything out that's new here how
many times I got to watch this movie
guys you know it seems to me I don't
know how many times we want to see this
movie again
but I think the American people have
moved on past this okay and he's not the
only one Lindsey Graham said I've heard
all I want to hear on this thing
it won't reshape my dynamic I've heard
all I need to hear from Muller our
Berta's report I accept the findings I
don't think it's gonna change public
opinion having been involved in the
Clinton impeachment if the public's not
with you you'll pay a price and I don't
think anything Muller can say that's
going to change anybody's mind now again
in the run-up to this there was a lot of
talk about maybe the Trump
administration was going to restrict
what Muller could testify that there's a
lot of talk about a particular letter
sent from the DOJ to Robert Muller that
basically said stick to the report so
why did that letter come about as it
turns out William bar the Attorney
General says that Muller actually
requested the letter so that he could
point to the letter when it came time
for him to testify at his press
conference
Bob had said that he intended to stick
with the public report and not go beyond
that and in conversations with the
department his staff was reiterating
that that was their position and they
asked us for guidance in writing to
explain or to tell them what our
position was so we responded in writing
the department sent the guidance they
had requested okay so this was all the
buildup in a second we are gonna get to
the punch line because it turns out that
the punch line didn't exactly match the
build up first nowadays there are a lot
of different types of cars on the road
there's no way that the local auto parts
store is going to supply you or stock
everything that you actually need
there's no reason why you should wait in
line to find the right part that's
probably overpriced or get the wrong
part that is overpriced anyway you can
do it all with the convenience of Rock
Auto the internet was made for this sort
of stuff guys Rock Auto comm it's a
family business serving Auto Parts
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers the
rockauto.com catalog it's unique it's
really easy to navigate I've checked it
out myself
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle choose the brands
specifications and prices that you
prefer best of all prices at
rockauto.com are always reliably low
that are the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers there's no reason to
spend up to twice
as much for it the same parts instead
use the internet webs they're great Rock
Auto calm amazing selection reliably low
prices all the parts your car will ever
need go to rock Auto calm right now see
all the parts available for your car or
truck right shapiro in there how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
sent you that helps us that also helps
them go check them out at Rock Auto calm
right now again right shapiro in there
how did you hear about us box and don't
waste your money shopping at the local
auto parts store when you could just go
to rockauto.com and get it done yourself
okay so as i say the media were prepared
they were prepared their body was ready
stephen colbert last night he was like
yeah this is gonna be the moment this
clip 21 this this whole thing is damning
evidence well it's gonna be oh it's
coming he turns into meg ryan from When
Harry Met Sally the Justice Department
has told Muller to limit his testimony
to what is in his report oh no now all
he's got is 448 pages of incredibly
damaging evidence that the president
committed 10 separate instances of
obstruction of justice and that at one
point he said and I quote okay well
again here is they're so excited did it
turn out to be exciting did it turn out
to be wonderful
not really no imagine that you're Robert
Muller imagine that you spend two years
working on this report or as it turns
out that you spend two your smoke and
chain smoking cigars out back well your
team rats here report as it appears is
what actually happened imagine that that
is your life and then you walk off
America's stage into the sunset having
done your work and then they call you
back in and they're like tell us what
tell us tell us what you said know what
God don't you people know how to read
that's pretty much how this went except
that Robert Muller was not the steadfast
Thoreau stolid public servant that the
people thought he was he looked pretty
precarious out there and this was the
critique from both right and left David
Axelrod was saying he looked old he
looked a little bit differing he looked
like he didn't really know what was
going on which did raise the question as
to how much of this report he actually
wrote this was a serious question
because there was a claim by President
Trump that it was actually Muller's team
that did most of the writing
Muller's deputy a guy named Andrew
Weisberg was a Hillary Clinton acolyte
mean who's at Hillary Clinton's elect
and headquarters the night that the
election actually happened he was a big
Hillary Clinton fan he apparently was
the lawyer for one of Hillary Clinton's
aides who helped smash their
BlackBerry's with a hammer and that guy
was was involved in the writing and so
there's claims today that given how
dicey Muller was on the stand here as I
see he was in his testimony that maybe
he wasn't actually in control of this
report in the first place that would
explain why you got that bizarre letter
from Muller's team to William Barr
suggesting that he did not fully
elucidate the findings of the reporter
that there had been some sort of
cover-up Muller doesn't look like he's
in control of the report I didn't look
like he was in control of himself you
know it was not a good showing for
Robert Miller who I think again is a
good man I have no evidence to the
contrary but he didn't look like he was
in control today and that was the
widespread critique here is a a mash-up
of robert muller repeatedly asking for
questions to be repeated this is clip 18
you could not publicly state that in
your report or here today can you repeat
the question sir is it correct that if
you had concluded okay and there's a lot
of this over and over could you repeat
the question I don't hear what you're
saying could you please repeat that
Muller did not look as though he was on
top of his game that for sure and that
was kind of the story that was kind of
the story now the Democrats got a couple
of talking points and the Republicans
got some talking points so the
Democratic talking point was obvious
president Trump oversold the findings of
the report in his own favor so President
Trump kept going out there and saying
I'm exonerated I'm cleared and as I said
at the time no you're not you're not
exonerated you are not cleared
particularly when it came to obstruction
may be on collusion but not on
obstruction and yet you're going out
there and saying totally exonerated
totally cleared that of course was never
true though the wording of the report
suggested it wasn't true so that was
always going to be an easy spot for
Democrats to hit and sure enough they
did in fact hit that this clip 20 robert
muller being asked if he exonerated the
president trump the president has
repeatedly claimed that your report
found there was no obstruction and that
it completely and totally exonerated him
but that is not what your report said is
it correct that is not what the report
said so the report did not conclude that
he did not commit obstruction of justice
is that correct
correct and what about total exoneration
did you actually totally exonerate the
president no now in fact your reports
expressly states that it does not
exonerate the president it does okay so
that was the talking point for the
Democrats coming out of this hearing but
there's one problem
which is that it wasn't mother's job to
exonerate the president he's a
prosecutor it was his job to determine
whether there was a prosecutable offense
and this became obvious in clip 16 when
representative Ratcliffe he said stammer
um you know you say you didn't exonerate
the president who said it's her job to
exonerate the president can you think of
another instance in which a prosecutor's
job is to exonerate anybody can you give
me the example other than Donald Trump
where the Justice Department determined
that an investigated person was not
exonerated because their innocence was
not conclusively determined I cannot but
this is unique okay well you can't
time is short I've got five minutes
let's just leave it it you can't find it
because I'll tell you why it doesn't
exist it was not the special counsels
job to conclusively determine Donald
Trump's innocence or to exonerate him
because the bedrock principle of our
justice system is a presumption of
innocence it exists for everyone
everyone is entitled to it including
sitting presidents okay that of course
is exactly right that's exactly right
and so that's the takeaway from the
Republicans so to take away from
Democrats is he wasn't exonerated may be
out there lurking somewhere like the
x-files is the actual damning material
and then John Radcliffe from Texas there
he says um dude that's not your job
you don't exonerate people you're not in
the exoneration people business that's
for defense counsel during a prosecution
your job is to determine whether there
is evidence sufficient to prosecute and
Muller basically admits yeah I guess
that's that's kind of right I guess
that's kind of it when one second we're
gonna get to the rest of Muller's
lackluster performance at best I mean it
really was lackluster he opened his
performance by suggesting for example
that he could not speak about the the
beginnings of the investigation he
suggested that he couldn't speak about
the steel dossier so there were key
topics that were left off the table
which immediately makes this much less
interesting he suggested in the middle
of this hearing he didn't know what
fusion GPS was which again was the
company that was hired by Hillary
Clinton's law firm to create the steel
dossier
really a bad performance for for Robert
Muller and not a good performance in
favor of Democrats we'll get to that in
a second first let's talk for a second
about how you preserve your memories and
one of the things that I think is most
important in life is making sure that
your memories are preserved because over
time they fade you don't remember what
your kids necessarily look like a couple
of years ago because you're with them
every day you don't remember what your
parents look like 20 years ago
and your parents are looking to preserve
their memories right now I think one of
the most important things that you can
do is preserve those memories and that's
why I love working with legacy Bach's
legacy box allows you to save your
family films and photos from degrading
or being lost forever and he got in your
garage and there's just boxes and boxes
of old photos and films and they're
being covered in dust and bugs are
eating away at them and they're
degrading over time they're getting
they're getting less easy to see the
quality of them is falling apart well
this is why you need a legacy box it
gives you peace of mind and a great
sense of accomplishment and ensures that
your family history is preserved forever
here's how it works you send your legacy
box filled with old home movies and
pictures and then they do the rest it
professionally digitized your moments
onto a thumb drive digital download or
DVD you can receive all your original
recorded moments back along with
perfectly preserved digital copies
legacy box is the world's largest most
trusted digitizer of home movies and
photos they've got over a decade of
experience all the work is done by hand
right here in the United States and
there has never been a better time to
digitally preserve your memories visit
legacy box calm right now get started
plus for a limited time you get an
exclusive discount because you're my
listener go to legacy box comm slash Ben
to get 40% off your first order
again that's legacy box comm slash Ben's
say 40% today get started preserving
your past it's not just a great gift
it's an important gift go to the legacy
box comm so I find I've used it myself
for my parents it's great legacy box
comm slash men get 40% off your first
order okay so two more of Muller's
testimony so Muller is is asked about
whether he found evidence sufficient for
culpability and the answer is no
representative Collins asks him about
this again this does not cut against the
president is it true the evidence
gathered during your investigation did
not establish that the president was
involved in the underlying crime related
to russian election interference as
stated in volume 1 page 7 we found
insufficient evidence of
the president's called culpability so
that would be a yes with that that'd be
a yes yes thank you okay so that not
good for Democrats right
insufficient culpability on the
underlying crime of collusion and then
he is asked okay so you you say that you
didn't find conspiracy and then you say
that you're unclear on collusion but in
your own report it says that collusion
and conspiracy are basically the same
thing doug collins is questioning from
georgia is very good right here and
muller just stumbles over himself muller
does not know his own report i mean that
is very obvious from this testimony he
keeps having to refer back to his report
the members of congress know his report
better than he does and that's because
his team probably wrote the report okay
what is clear now is that Muller was not
doing the vast majority of the work in
compiling the report it was his team
which makes sense I mean he had a big
team of lawyers he oversees that team of
lawyers he probably reads the final
report and then gives his sign off on it
but in no way is Muller the expert on
his own report and that is obvious
because he keeps getting caught off
guard when people ask him specific
questions about his own report and again
he started off this thing by saying that
he was not going to comment on some of
the most confusing aspects of the report
such as for example why fusion GPS is
bit basically not mentioned I mean that
was a an intelligence-gathering group
hired by hillary clinton's law firm in
order to go get the steal dossier which
was used as the basis for much of the
investigation how was that not within
the FBI's purview how about the
beginning of the investigation he says
well that was before my time and not
within my purview well the entire
investigation was about Russian
interference in the 2016 election so
wouldn't you want to know how the
investigation was initiated considering
that the Republicans have been accusing
the investigation of being initiated off
the basis of Russian interference in
collusion basically with Hillary
Clinton's campaign so you took a bunch
of key issues off the table from the
very beginning here is Doug Collins
forcing Muller to stumble on collusion
and conspiracy and pointing out that
when you say they are unclear on
collusion but there's no conspiracy
you're really saying no collusion
although your report states collusion is
not so specific Alf Anson you said that
this morning or a term of art and
federal criminal law of conspiracy is
and the colloquial context are collusion
and conspiracy essentially synonymous
terms you're going
repeat that for me collusion is not a
specific offense or a term of art in the
federal criminal law conspiracy is yes
in the colloquial context known public
contents collusion collusion and
conspiracy are essentially synonymous
terms correct no no so then they're not
synonymous terms and then Collins goes
on and he actually refers specifically
specifically to a quote from the from
the actual manifesto from this 448 page
report in which they equate collusion
and conspiracy and Muller has forced her
back to the report I mean it was really
really a bad thing for him it just it
did not it did not pay off for Robert
Muller or for Democrats at any point
here it was a very very bad day for
Democrats Muller was asked by
representative Collins here's a key
takeaway representative column says to
Muller was your investigation hindered
at any point or curtailed that would be
the key question when it comes to
obstruction did anybody do anything to
your investigation and Miller says no no
the investigation was your investigation
controlled or curtailed or stopped or
hindered no okay that would be the key
takeaway now what Democrats are trying
to latch on to is this suggestion that
in reality Muller wants Trump prosecuted
after Trump leaves office and they're
hanging that that coat on a very very
slender hook okay and that is an
exchange in which Robert Muller is asked
specifically if president from could be
prosecuted after he leaves office and
this is the new clip okay and here is
Muller's answer and I'll explain why
Democrats are wrongly jumping on this
answer could you charge the president
with a trim' after he left office yes
you believe that he committed you could
charge the president nine states with
obstruction of justice after he left
office yes okay so that does not so
Democrats are saying well that's the key
takeaway isn't it I mean he could be
charged after he leaves office
technically he can be charged after he
leaves office this does not answer the
question as to whether he should be
charged after he leaves office I could
be charged today that doesn't answer the
question as to whether I should be
charged today as a
matter of law of course the president
can be charged after he leaves office
for crimes committed while his
presidents of the United States however
that was not the question that Muller
was asked and had he been asked that
question presumably he would not have
answered the question properly again the
the the Democrats are really attempting
to spin this into something that it is
not because the the answer is this has
been a giant nothing burger and Miller
does not acquit himself well Muller said
that the investigation did not establish
Trump campaign conspiracy with Russia he
said that openly the investigation did
not establish that members of the Trump
campaign conspired with the Russian
government in its election interference
activities and then Muller basically
said that's all I'm talking about I'm
talking about the stuff that's in the
report I'm not gonna talk about any of
the other stuff that you guys want to
know about so he won't talk about fusion
GPS he apparently doesn't know what
fusion GP I mean this is an amazing
moment you're the head of the Muller
investigation because your name is
Robert Muller and it's your
investigation you've never heard of
fusion GPS is there anybody who has been
following this thing for two years who
doesn't know what fusion GPSS and yet
Muller clip 22 says to representives
Chabot he says I don't know what fusion
GPS it you don't know what fusion how I
do everyone has been following this does
I thought that you wrote the report dude
when you talk about the the firm that
produced the steel reporting the name of
the firm that produced that was fusion
GPS is that correct it's not it's not a
trick question I mean it was fusion GPS
now fusion GPS produced the opposition
research document widened widely known
as the steel dossier and the owner of
Hughes and GPA was someone named Glenn
Simpson are you familiar with this is
outside my purview
okay oh it's outside his purview why why
is it outside his purview again the
entire investigation was about Russian
interference in the election if fusion
GPS was funneled Russian disinformation
via Christopher steel and that became a
part of the investigation how exactly is
that outside the purview of his
investigation and it gets worse Muller
says I can't answer any questions about
the initial opening of the
VI investigation really why wouldn't
that be sort of important to determining
for example how this whole thing came
about and whether it was legit or not
the Justice Department has asserted
privileges concerning investigative
information and decisions ongoing
matters within the Justice Department
and deliberations within our office
these are Justice Department privileges
that I will respect the department has
released the letter discussing the
restrictions on my testimony I therefore
will not be able to answer questions
about certain areas that I know are of
public interest for example I am unable
to address questions about the initial
opening of the FBI's Russia
investigation which occurred months
before my appointment okay so in the end
train wreck train wreck Matt gets
followed up on all of this he said can
you state with confidence the steel
dossier was not part of Russia's to
disinformation campaign and Miller says
with regard to steel that's beyond my
purview and Matt Gaetz says it's exactly
your purview the organizing principle
was to fully investigate Russia's
interference well yes yes the what a
mess what an absolute mess and it's not
just conservatives who are saying so so
Chris Wallace is one of the more
objective reporters on Fox News and he
says correctly he says this thing was a
disaster for Democrats it was a disaster
for mark he looked terrible
it was awful frankly I think you've all
both been very kind I think this has
been a disaster for the Democrats and I
think it's been a disaster for the
reputation of robert muller he has
seemed very uncertain with his brief he
doesn't know seemed to know what things
that are in the report he's been
attacked a number of times and you would
think that almost anybody else would
have defended his own integrity and the
integrity of the investigation okay but
that's not what happened so in the end
does any of this matter no it doesn't so
Democrats who have been trying
desperately to continue to push the
Russia stuff desperately trying to push
the obstruction stuff it's just gonna
fall apart on them it's absolutely going
to fall apart on them and it should fall
apart on them it was a mistake for them
to comala Muller was never gonna give
them what what they were
the best that he was going to do is
repeat some of the more incendiary
reports from the report but everybody
had that out there and Democrats can cut
ads on that stuff anytime or give
speeches on it at any time Muller
appeared confused it appeared as though
he wasn't in control of his own team he
didn't know his own report it basically
looked like when your parent wrote your
book report for you in third grade and
you went in there and your teacher was
like so tell us what happened in Bridge
to Terabithia you're like uh what
because your parents read it that's what
it felt like from Robert Muller
can you repeat the question bad bad
showing for Robert Muller and we're
showing four democrats who thought that
this was going to be the moment finally
the moment when President Trump went
down not the case giant fail right now
the testimony you know is is going to
continue to be a news story but I don't
think that this is actually going to to
be news beat I don't think no one cares
about this frankly I think that this was
over the moment that the report came out
and there was no recommendation of
prosecution there's no place for
Democrats to go from there if Democrats
want to impeach on this basis I don't
think the American people are for it I
don't think that the polls show that the
American people are for it and bringing
Robert Miller up there hoping that he
was going to open some other can of
worms or point to the shadowy man in the
back and say ah deep throat here he is
it never happened it wasn't going to
happen so end of story
but will it be the end of what will CNN
do for the next two years that really is
the question I mean while the media have
another purview they have another agenda
and their agenda is they must at any
cost defend Ilhan Omar so President
Trump has decided he's going to go to
war with el hun Omar that's gonna be as
2020 campaign ilhan Omar vs. President
Trump and that's pretty smart because
the fact is that Ilhan Omar is not
popular the more people see of her the
less popular she is that is not because
she is black that is not because she is
a woman that is not because she is
Muslim it's because she's terrible it's
because she says routinely anti-semitic
things it's because she says things like
some people did something on 9/11 it's
because her sneering tone of voice when
she describes the United States is
extraordinarily off-putting it's because
she treats I mean she literally said
legislative bodies in the United States
are more interested in treating dogs
decently than humans
there's a reason folks are not real fond
of Ilhan Omar president Trump has
decided he's going to make her his bait
Noir in all of this
speaking at Turning Point USA great
organization and here is president Trump
making this point and she's just
screaming and this was this is not a
sane person folks when you look at that
and this is what we're up against you
have some of that now your other friend
from an incredible state right a state
that I'm gonna win Minnesota you know
that one and you know why I'm gonna win
this thing because of her I almost
wanted less than we came with just about
a point that's a very because Minnesota
is a very hard one for a Republican to
win we almost wanted one more night I
wanted to go there one more time
I said I'm telling you we're gonna win
Minnesota okay so Trump is is really
leaning heavily into the Ilhan Omar of
all of this and again that makes sense
when I say that she's an anti-semite
it's because she's an anti-semite she
accused Israel of quote-unquote
hypnotizing the world which is not an
accusation of Israeli policy being bad
it's an accusation that the Jewish state
is hypnotizing the world she suggested
that American support for Israel is
quote unquote all about the Benjamins
she accused everybody who supports
Israel of having dual loyalty to the
State of Israel and she's back the
anti-semitic BDS movement so what are
the media doing they're out there in
force defending Ilhan Omar in one of the
great gaslighting articles I have ever
seen there's a BuzzFeed contributor
named chase Modar who wrote a piece
called Ilhan Omar's anti-semitism is
becoming a load bearing myth for the
America for American politics just like
hippies spitting on Vietnam vets or
welfare queens sipping champagne
Omar's anti-semitism has become a
structural support beam for American
politics and then he says well she never
actually said anything that was
anti-semitic really so then why did she
apologize
under pressure from Nancy Pelosi and
other top members of the House caucus
just a couple of months ago for her
anti-semitic remarks and then like two
weeks later she went right back to the
anti-semitism why was her first move
since national prominence hit her again
why was her first moved to sponsor a
resolution comparing Israel to the Nazis
from 1933 to 1941 she's not an
anti-semite though according to the
press this is all everything according
to the press everything Trump says is
wrong so even when he says something
right they treat it as though it is
wrong are indubitably wonderful fact
checkers and decent people in the media
don't worry
they're here just to tell you the truth
defending Ilhan Omar we'll get to more
of that in just one second and why this
actually is really bad for Democrats why
they'd be better off cutting her loose
and recognizing her for what she is
they're making a large-scale mistake but
first this month marks the fiftieth
anniversary since we first put a man on
the moon there's an exciting new podcast
by esoteric radio theater it's called
Apollo 11 what we saw it immediately
rocketed to number three on iTunes Apple
podcast it stayed in the top 10 for a
week and it's getting rave reviews from
everybody who listens to it it is
fantastic almost 1 million people have
listened to the podcast or watched on
YouTube so far you should be one of them
the host is Bill Whittle author of
pilots NASA enthusiasts knows more about
NASA and pretty much anybody that I've
ever heard of he tells you the story of
the journey of getting to the moon and
what happened when we got there and how
things almost went horribly wrong all
four episodes are available right now
head on over to Apple podcast or
wherever you listen to podcast and
subscribe today to Apollo 11 what we saw
you can also watch we produced this
beautiful video episodes they include
tons of amazing space historical footage
over there at esoteric radio theater
YouTube channel really is worth the
watch go check it out right now also
make sure that you tune in today at 7
p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific for our
latest episode of the conversation host
Andrew Clavin
not me thank God we'll be answering your
questions live on air so make them good
the episode is free to watch on Facebook
and YouTube only subscribers can ask the
questions so head on over subscribe it's
daily where get your questions answered
by Clavin today at 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m.
Pacific and go join the conversation
it'll be well worth your time also I
mean while you're at it why don't just
subscribe to daily wire comm in general
because it'll make your life 1,000 times
better you get the annual subscription
for $99 a year magical and that comes
along with this the very greatest in
beverage vessels the leftist years how
to recall tumblr cast your eyes upon it
and despair that you have it not but you
could if you just joined our team by the
way the real reason you should join the
team beyond all the great benefits
beyond being part of the mailbag and
being able to have early access to VIP
tickets at our events and beyond two
additional hours of the show you get
every single but beyond all of that one
of the magical things is that you help
defend us from the nastiness of the left
that seeks 2d platform everyone they
disagree with when you join up that's
what helps us bring you the show so
please become part of the team subscribe
over daily wire.com we're the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
you
so as I say the media are out in full
force defending Ilhan Omar why because
Donald Trump opposes her of course so
this means they are now going to
Gaslight all of us it's so funny the
media are constantly accusing Trump of
gaslighting Americans and there's some
truth to that Trump says things
routinely that are simply not true
in order to achieve a partisan political
end in this he is mirrored by the
mainstream media which we've been doing
this for my entire lifetime they've been
doing this for my entire lifetime and
they have not stopped one iota
they've accelerated that problem since
President Trump became president so
BuzzFeed has an entire article today
about how Ilhan Omar's anti-semitism is
a myth it's a myth okay there's a
columnist who says the rabidly
anti-semitic comments that Omar never
made along with the equally fictitious
Jew hatred of her allies in the so
called squad have swiftly become a
load-bearing myth in u.s. politics
really it's a myth
okay so Rasheeda Talib associating with
a bevy of anti-semites inviting an open
anti-semite to give her a painting at
her inauguration Ilhan Omar hanging out
with Linda Sarsour rabid anti-semite aoc
doing the same thing all of them hanging
out with Jeremy Corbyn the first
resolution that L had Omar sponsors
being a resolution that compares Israel
to the Nazi Party and then receded to
leave getting up on the floor of the US
House and doing the same thing it's all
a myth it's all in your head guys so
either this BuzzFeed columnist fell and
hit his head and ended up in an
alternative reality like sliding doors
or we all did because I'm living in the
reality where I shoot it to lead
yesterday said this on the House floor
so I can't stand by and watch this
attack on our freedom of speech and the
right to boycott the racist policies of
the government in the State of Israel
Americans of conscience have long and
proud history of participating and
boycotts specifically to advocate for
human rights abroad Americans boycotted
Nazi Germany in response to
dehumanization imprisonment and genocide
of Jewish people okay and the media are
out defending this in force today Dana
Millbank columnist over at The
Washington Post has a piece called ill
hen Omar quintessentially American
quintessentially I mean not just she's
American true she's an immigrant to the
United States who is legal and has her
citizenship she is American
quintessentially American like the
most American the most American why is
she the most American well sure she says
stuff on a routine basis that's gross
sure she does but I mean but but really
in the end isn't she more American than
Trump this is dana Milbank case he says
oh my remains ill-defined beyond the
monstrous caricature the president has
made of her with his racist slander okay
it's not a monstrous caricature to point
out that she has gone easy on terrorists
she did if she wrote a letter in support
of people attempting to join Isis to a
judge in which she suggested that those
are people who are just angry because of
their socioeconomic status and that they
should be let off the hook because they
are just pursuing change by other means
she says that in her letter she is in
fact an anti-semite she has not made any
secret of this Minnesota Democrats in
her own district have said that for
years she has been saying it this sort
of stuff but it's a monstrous caricature
she's one of four non white
Congresswomen the squad who Trump
proposes should go back to the countries
from which they came even though three
were born in the United States by the
way little little side note both her she
did to leave a new head Omar have told
people to go back where they came from
in the past few years on Twitter there's
gonna point that out that's not justify
what the president says but let's just
say that these women have not been shy
in their own rhetoric about people they
do shoot it to leave in 2015
told Trump that he should be deported
okay so before everybody starts going
off on the like no one who's rational
would say this sort of thing I agree it
is not a rational thing to say
Rashidah Talib and president Trent like
it's funny though the media just dismiss
it when it comes from rashida to leave
when Trump says it of course then we
have to take it super SuperDuper
seriously but Rasheeda Talib is the
greatest and most innocent and wise
among us
same thing with el han omar dana Milbank
says omar who immigrated from somalia as
a child was the target of the
center-back chance at Trump's rally last
week which we on the show condemned in
very harsh terms and of trumps
unsubstantiated suggest suggestion that
she once married her own brother well
not totally unsubstantiated the
Minneapolis star-tribune has been
investigating that and there's fairly
good evidence that she committed some
sort of immigration fraud with this dude
she certainly committed marital fraud
when she filed her tax returns minutes
before Omar took the stage Tuesday at
the Muslim Caucus education collective
conference in Washington Trump tweeted
about America hating anti-semite
representative Omar who along with the
others in the squad is a nightmare for
America for Trump's racist base
Omar has it all black female Muslim
immigrant yeah that's what it is that's
that's surely what it is because that
same base by the way despises Nancy
Pelosi but Dana Millbank says Omar he
admits this is the part where they admit
well you know she's not she might have a
few problems but in the end isn't she
more American than you dana Milbank says
Omar previously heard her cause when her
criticism of Israel crossed into
anti-semitism displaying the same sort
of prejudice that has often directed at
Muslims I even loved the phraseology
there right at the real problem with
what el hand Omar said about Jews is
that it really mimics what people say
about Muslims not that it's bad in and
of itself but that you know just as
people say this stuff about Muslims
something she kind of she slipped into
it slipped a banana peel right into
anti-semitism she may revert again says
dana Milbank but the woman I saw Tuesday
represented American values far better
than the bigoted demagogue who has made
her his bete noire really she may revert
again I love that can you imagine that
in any other context sure he just
slipped right into racism he may revert
again but isn't he's SuperDuper American
isn't he the most American actually the
media out in full force to defend it
will head over by the way the Democrats
are not out in full force defending
Ilhan Omar so Ilhan Omar sponsors this
resolution that would cut in support of
boycott divestment sanctions from Israel
one month ago Nancy Pelosi spoke at APEC
and called that exact policy
anti-semitic one month ago not a word
from Nancy Pelosi she's still not been
asked about it but presumably for seeing
that she might be asked about it Nancy
Pelosi then sponsored an anti BDS
resolution on the House floor and thus
anti BDS resolution basically said BDS
is a bad idea it was non-binding
resolution that opposes the boycott
movement against Israel a measure the
one broad bipartisan support but faced
pushback from some high-profile
progressives let me note here let me
note here the headline from CNN so House
approves resolution opposing Israel
boycott movement in divisive vote can
you imagine any other vote that goes 398
to 17 that is called divisive any other
wrote that is what we call nearly
unanimous so we're not talking about
like 200 something to 200 something
that's how we're talking about here
we're not even talking about 230 to 198
or something we are talking about 398 to
17 and CNN calls a divisive why is it
divisive
because members of the squad were on the
side of the 17 the resolution was
introduced in March
not long after Democrats faced a
bruising internal debate over how to
handle comments and tweets by
representative Ilhan Omar that were
criticized as being anti-semitic now
notice again how CNN characterizes this
so no hon Omar says something
anti-semitic it's that they were
criticized as being anti-semitic but
when Trump says something that is
criticized as being racist
they just say racist straight-out right
in the headline so it's always Ilhan
Omar controversial figure Donald Trump
racist the way they cover this stuff is
wildly inconsistent of course the
resolution supports a two-state solution
argues that BDS movement is an effort to
gee legitimized Israel which is true of
course and urges Israelis and
Palestinians to return to direct
negotiations Omar as well as Rasheeda
Talib have been openly supportive of the
BDS movement and critical of the
resolution AOC also voted against the
resolution by the way AO AO sees quote
on this is astonishingly bad so AOC was
asked about why she voted against a
resolution to condemn BDS and her answer
is wild she actually suggested that the
reason that you shouldn't oppose BDS is
because if you oppose BDS it might force
people into violence so you should have
you should support soft anti-semitism
softer anti-semitism because otherwise
you might lead to violent anti-semitism
can you imagine her saying that in any
other context no we should really like
be okay with white supremacist rhetoric
because you never know they might turn
into terrorists so better that they
should and then just talk about it then
be terrorists it's this is all insane
it's all insane and of course it's very
bad for the Democratic Party so keep it
up guys well done everybody
and meanwhile in other big news the
Justice Department is now looking at
going after big tech according to Brent
Kendall over at The Wall Street Journal
the Justice Department is opening a
broad antitrust review into whether
dominant technology firms are unlawfully
stifling competition adding a new
Washington threat for companies such as
Facebook Google Amazon and Apple the
review is geared toward examining the
practices of online platforms that
dominate internet search social media
and retail services the department said
confirming the review shortly after the
Wall Street Journal reported it the new
antitrust inquiry under a G bar could
ratchet up the already
considerable regulatory pressures facing
the top US tech firms now as I've said
before I am not in favor of regulating
big tech unless they've actually
violated the law but the big problem for
big tech is that they've been utterly
non transparent in many cases to what
they are doing this is particularly true
of the social media platforms basically
people see data points and then they
assume that the data points are
representative of broader trends inside
these various companies and this leads
them to be angry and feel like they are
out of control and feel like they were
lied to because for example if you use
Google and you think that Google is
going to provide you with some sort of
unbiased result and then it turns out
that behind the scenes Google is
manipulating the algorithm and not
making clear to you what exactly they
are doing and it makes you feel like you
are being taken advantage of and lack of
transparency also it doesn't really
allow for the sort of competition that
you'd want because suspicion alone is
really not a great basis to form a
company like if Google were to just say
listen you want your left-leaning search
results you come to us then people would
start going to DuckDuckGo and they would
actually get less biased results same
thing is true with Facebook and so I've
met with some of these tech leaders and
I've said to them you want not to be
regulated I'm not in favor of regulation
I think putting the government in charge
of stuff is a really bad idea but the
drive for this is stemming directly from
your lack of transparency and you need
to be transparent with the American
people and you have not been transparent
on everything from privacy to how you
make decisions on who gets been and who
gets demonetized and if you're not going
to be transparent people are going to
take their suspicions and they're going
to suggest that that actually is is the
governing fact now using antitrust to go
after these companies seems to me a
massive mistake the reason being
particularly with Amazon for example
what exactly did Amazon do wrong that
they have violated antitrust so there
are two models of antitrust and they're
in conflict model one of antitrust law
was sort of the pre Robert Bork model so
Robert Bork wrote a very famous book
called the antitrust paradox the
antitrust paradox posited that antitrust
laws were designed for consumer benefit
that the reason you break up a company
is because the company is an
anti-competitive and is harming
consumers so for example you have two
companies and they would be in
competition with one another lowering
price but they decide to make a regional
regional split and you take the western
United States and we take the eastern
United States and
we'll collude to keep prices up right
that would be anti-competitive and thus
would be subject to antitrust in the
Robert Bork view however you have one
company that is providing you with
wonderful services and that those
services are really good and there are
no competitors because it's just a good
business and it's efficient more could
say that's not an antitrust problem the
other model is that any company that is
too big should be broken up and I fear
that model because it is completely
subjective
what exactly is too big what does too
big look like how do you decide that
Walmart shouldn't be broken up but
Amazon should how do you decide that big
firms that you like should not be broken
up a big firms that you don't should not
be broken up it's like a dollar cut off
or a market percentage cut off how do
you decide if a company decides to
purchase vertically integrate its own
business is this monopolistic now just
because they wanted to save money by not
having to outsource their labor most
companies at some point will do some
sort of vertical integration with a with
an independent company that they were
once doing business with so for example
we here at daily wire bought a marketing
firm that we were doing business with
why because it was cheaper for us to buy
the marketing firm than it was for us to
simply outsource to the marketing firm
that doesn't violate antitrust that is
us growing our business in the most
efficient way and a lot of places do
this sort of stuff the problem with the
model that is being used to go after a
lot of these tech companies is it it's
extraordinary vague you have to find the
wrongdoing before you start accusing
antitrust so to take an example of the
vagueness Andrew Ross Sorkin over on
CNBC is interviewing Steve Newton the
Treasury secretary and minuchin is
talking about Amazon and here's what he
has to say
justice said yesterday that they're
going to look into some of the big tech
companies that were at the White House
yesterday in fact and consider the
antitrust issues that are involved do
you believe that they are that they're
hurting competition I think as you know
if you look at Amazon although they're
you know there's certain benefits to it
they've destroyed the retail industry
across the United States so there's no
question they've limited competition
there's areas where they've really hurt
small businesses so I don't think this
is a one-size-fits-all and I don't you
know I don't have an opinion going in
other than I think it's absolutely right
that the Attorney General is looking
into these issues you think I'm a little
bit off base
when I say the government should be in
charge of these issues that is the Vegas
stupidest standard I've ever heard of
course Amazon has hurt the retail
industry why because you're getting
products cheaper delivered directly to
your door via Amazon than you would if
you went out to the retail store
that's not Amazon's fault that's because
brick-and-mortar installations have been
on the downturn for approximately a
decade and a half and that's because
there's a thing called the internet and
shipping
that's not Amazon unfairly restraining
business that's ridiculous and you think
I want to put the FTC in charge of
Facebook policing content neutrality
what happens when Camilla Harris is
president and then appoints the majority
of the FTC and she decides that
neutrality means that you have to get
rid of voices she doesn't like by the
way that something left is perfectly
fine with doing folks on the left
suggest that neutrality does not mean
that the right should be allowed on the
platform they believe that neutrality
means only fact should be spoken and
when they say fact what they mean is
leftist perspective this is an agenda
that is pushed by an enormous number of
people on the left when they say well we
don't want fake balance
well we actually want is just the truth
and the truth is the world is how we see
it this is why I push back against a lot
of the push from the right that we
should regulate Facebook but as I say to
these companies you want the right to
rally around a sort of libertarian
principle that you should be left alone
you need to be transparent you need to
tell us what you are doing that doesn't
mean you have to give away proprietary
algorithms it does mean we need to know
the inputs we need to know what are the
factors you are using to decide whether
or not to downgrade news when you say
what at Facebook for example that we
need trusted sources how are you
deciding what a trusted source looks
like is that decided by the same people
who like CNN in the New York Times
because then you're taking the endemic
mistrust of the media and you're
filtering it up to Facebook we didn't
trust CNN or the New York Times now
you're calling them trusted sources and
benefiting them what do you think we are
going to think of you do we feel like
that is a restraint of trade in the
sense that you're downplaying particular
companies without actually telling them
that's happening and there are no rivals
in the market it leaves the door open so
more transparency from big tech is the
solution to this government pressure for
more transparency voluntary transparency
seems good the sort of arbitrary nature
of antitrust law being used to target
businesses that are not liked on one
side of the political I or another I
think that's a huge huge hue
mistake wait till Elizabeth Warren is in
charge guys and then you'll see how much
you enjoy this routine okay time for
some things that I like so things that I
like today there is a series that I was
unaware of called Legion it is based on
comic book series and it stars the dude
from Downton Abbey I can never remember
his name Dan something Dan Stevens and
the series is really quirky and really
weird and it's also pretty compelling
it's about a superhero who is a telepath
but he thinks that he's a paranoid
schizophrenic and so it's shot in this
really weird jolty bizarre style it's
kind of fascinating it's pretty
psychedelic here's a little bit of the
preview of Legion just tell me what
happened next you win a few medication
looking for the truth which you promise
to tell
I told you the hooker Sydney Barrett the
girl who disappeared she didn't
disappear she took my place like the
curse white button okay the show is
really weird and really quirky and white
bizarre so you can check it out it's
it's kind of fun okay other things that
I like today so today is the day today
is the day in which all secrets are
revealed we learned earlier today that
Robert Miller basically had nothing he
suggested at one point during his
testimony that he did not indict Trump
because of the OLC opinion that you
can't say indict a sitting president but
then he also suggested that principles
of fairness the principles of fairness
were involved in other words there are
no real big talking points for the
Democrats coming out of that hearing
Muller had nothing right Muller did not
have the goods on President Trump and
Democrats were hoping that he would
spill the goods on President Trump that
all fell apart for them so there was a
day of that secret revealed it is also a
day in which the story of State
Representative Erika Thomas completely
comes apart so you'll recall state
representative Erica Thomas of Georgia
just a few days ago she claimed over the
weekend that she was at a Publix grocery
store and she was in the checkout line
and she was in the express checkout line
with fifteen to twenty items and a man
said to her ma'am you are in the express
checkout line and you have too many
items and she apparently according to
the dude started screaming at him at
which point he called her lazy and then
she claims that he told her to go back
where she came from
it deliberately evoking the words of
President Trump with regard to the squad
and deliberately evoke him the chance of
the crowd with regard to Ilhan Omar and
that was the that was the pitch the
pitch for the story was that trumpian
racism and xenophobia is broadly
crossing the country and here is an
example of it hitting somebody in their
everyday life she's just an innocent
woman at the grocery store and this evil
white Republican comes up and starts
quoting Trump at her well wearing a mega
hat and carrying a subway sandwich or
something okay and and then it turns you
out not so much the guy who she
confronted who confronted her was
apparently a Cuban Democrat not only
that he fully did I did she ever said
that and then she came out and said um
yeah he might not have said
where he came from I might have just
sort of made that up well now there was
witness testimony as to what exactly
happened in this case is according to
the Atlanta journal-constitution quote a
witness to a heated grocery store
encounter between state Rep Erika Thomas
and a man she accused of uttering racist
comments told to authorities she didn't
hear him make those remarks according to
a Cobb County police report a Publix
employee told the Cobb County officer
that she witnessed part of the
conversation and heard Thomas
continually tell Eric sparks to quote go
back where you came from but did not
hear sparks utter those words to Thomas
so in other words it sounds like she
completely made this up and not only did
she make it up she's the one who said
this to the guy it's so she claims this
white man came and said go back where
you came from and she's weeping in the
video she's crying because how could
this sort of racism bigotry exist in
America and then I was like I actually
lady you said that to him so you got
this right but like not at all well the
photo negative sparks admitted calling
the Democrat an expletive during the run
and saying he was upset she was at an
express aisle in the grocery store with
too many items but he said he didn't
tell her to go back where she came from
Thomas's attorney Gerald Griggs said the
officers report shows the case needs
additional investigation aha because the
employee and another witness who also
said he didn't hear sparks use the
phrase quote didn't hear the initial
argument he said he's interviewed three
other customers who heard the exchange
top authorities said they don't intend
to file criminal charges in the case
right because not criminal even if he
said that that's not criminal this is
still the United States we don't
prosecute people for saying mean things
to one another the back and forth has
led to new scrutiny says the AJC Atlanta
journal-constitution that mirrors the
nation's political divide some
conservatives cast thomas has a version
of justice Millette I mean so far that
sort of the evidence isn't it so all of
this has fallen apart for her it is a
day of secrets revealed it turns out
that she apparently said exactly the
thing according to witness testimony
that she claims that the bad guy said
sparks made a statement on Tuesday he
said he wasn't surprised that cobb
authorities decided not to file charges
he said the police report speaks for
itself he says everyone that knows me
knows I'm anti-hate anti bigot anti
racism
sadly too much of media is in fact
checking items or they're just taking
the word of a politician when they do a
live Facebook or a Twitter post correct
okay so that is a story of the day when
it comes to secrets being revealed other
secrets being revealed according to a
man depressed a giacomo over a daily
wire comm senator Bernie Sanders is 2020
presidential campaign has been hit with
an unfair labor practice complaint
according to the National Labor
Relations Board it turns out that he's a
vicious brutal capitalist
turns out that Bernie Sanders as I've
said before marks in the streets Hayek
in the sheets baby
that guy is that that guy is ready to
crack down on his labor force when he
needs more work from them for the same
pay the complaint was filed on July 19th
by an individual in Indiana who claims
that the Sanders campaign took part in
illegal employee interrogation and
retaliation against staffers according
to Bloomberg law a copy of the char has
not yet been made public charge has not
yet been made public but the agency's
July 22nd docket lists five potential
violations of the National Labor
Relations Act here are the five
allegations one concerted activities
retaliation discharge discharge
discipline repudiation mediation of
contract and interrogation including
polling the complaint is just more
embarrassing news for the
self-identified Democratic Socialist
over the weekend of course Bernie
Sanders had to cut staffers hours to
accommodate his routinely advocated $15
minimum wage he also scolded some on his
campaign for going to the press to
discuss the internal negotiations pretty
awesome stuff so the National Labor
Relations Board is going to now be
investigating Bernie Sanders because all
justice shall be done so good times good
times I'm pleased to see that Bernie
Sanders is learning that his own
employees may not in fact be the best
employees and that Bernie Sanders has
been relegated to now treating them in
vicious capitalist terrible terrible
ways I will say it would not surprise me
at all if it turns out that one of these
staffers is just basically a member of
another campaign in disguise and this is
an attempt to take down Sanders I think
that's a possibility okay time for a
quick thing that I hate now at the same
time that Democrats like Bernie Sanders
are being hit with relations and
National Labor Relations Board charges
at the same time the Democrats are being
hit
with that bill de blasio is pitching a
new bill of rights for employees that
would outlaw firing them here is bill de
blasio with his crazy plans as he
strangles a groundhog under the table
giant weird bill de blasio unpopular in
his own town
now campaigning for presidents on the
basis of being weird oh here he is my
proposal is really clear and it's I call
it a Bill of Rights on purpose because
it's not just enough to give lip service
to working people we need to enshrine
these rights so for example right now in
America folks can get fired for no cause
whatsoever this legislation I'm
proposing and what I would enact as
president is that there has to be just
cause for any termination there has to
be due process right now in America
there's no guarantee of time off no
matter how much you work every other
industrialized country in the world
guarantees paid vacation days but this
one my proposals minimum two weeks paid
vacation for every American worker we're
going to put that into law in New York
this year okay so you are going to have
a right to a voice on the job so
apparently you can you can completely
humiliate your employer and say whatever
you want in the workplace which is going
to work until somebody says something
conservative which point they're fired
there will be a right to paid time off
which again is a right against an
employer that you bargained with to take
the job but if you don't want to take
the paid time off or what if the
employer can't hire as many people
specifically because now he has to pay
you to take vacation but most of all the
idea that an employer is supposed to
tell the government why they're firing
an employee you want to gum up the labor
market you want to make it so that
people are less likely to hire people
they find risky this is the way to do it
really the predictable result of this is
that people are less likely to hire the
marginal employee so you're only going
to hire the employee that you think is
guaranteed to do the job so the people
who are going to be hurt the hardest by
this the hurt the most are people who
have a bad record of employment people
who probably I would guess just based on
statistics are minorities because if you
hire somebody who's minority and then
they claim that you're firing them
because of racism and you say well no
I'm just firing you because you're a bad
employee it's a lot harder to do that
then presumably then presumably if you
hire a white employee and you fire him
because he's doing a bad job it's hard
for him to claim racism there are
predictable effects to all of this but
Democrats don't care about predictable
effects all they care about is the
virtue signaling of clean
employers are evil and employees are
wonderful all of which is sometimes true
and is mostly not true mostly it turns
out that employers and employees are
fairly good people overall and that when
people get fired very often it's because
they're not doing the job or because
there's a conflict trying to police this
stuff on the government level is pretty
tyrannical but I guess Bill DeBlasio is
used to that okay we'll be back here
later for two additional hours of
content more on the ongoing Muller saga
we'll be back then see you then I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily weiter
2019 hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show Robert Muller
is testifying before the House Judiciary
Committee today and earlier this morning
a Volkswagen pulled into the Capitol
Rotunda and onlookers watched with
delight and wonder as all 235
congressional Democrats poured out of
the car until committee chairman Jerry
Nadler finally emerged wearing a baggy
polkadot outfit gigantic shoes white
makeup and a fright wig and announced to
reporters that he did not want the
hearing to turn into some kind of circus
we'll talk about it on the Andrew Clavin
show I'm Andrew Clavin